كلمه الولايات المتحده امام مؤتمر الامن
في ميونخ كانت مناسبه لعرض التجاوزات
الروسيه في اوكرانيا من تعذيب واغتصاب
وقصف لمدني
نظرنا في الادله نعرف المعايير القانونيه
وليس هناك ادنى شك انها جرائم بحق
الانسانيه
وزير الخارجيه
رحب بالاعلان الامريكي واتهم موسكو مجددا
بشن حرب اباده في اوكرانيا مبديا خشيته من
امكانيه جمع ما يكفي من الادله لملاحقه
افراد محددين ارتكبوا فضاعات امام القضاء
كما اعتبرت هاريس ان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين قد فشل في تقسيم الناتو
مبديه انزعاجها من تعزيز بيكين لعلاقاتها
مع موسكو
ان اي خطوات تتخذها الصين في المستقبل
لتقديم المساعده لروسيا لن تؤدي الا الى
تاكيد العدوان ومواصله القتل وتقويض نظام
قائم على مبادئ القانون غير ان وزير
الخارجيه الصيني اكد ان بلاده نصيره
للسلام دعيا موسكو واكياف الى الجلوس حول
الطاوله وايجاز حل سياسي للنزاع اذ يامل
الاوروبيون من بكين استخدام نفوذها لدى
موسكو من اجل وضع حد للحرب